cardi b
is living her best life on vacation and
it has us wondering
where was our invite i know that's right
on monday the rapper showed off her
tropical getaway on instagram
which included yachts smoothies tacos
and an
unusual dip in the ocean
the vacay took place after cardi's new
single up rose to number one on the
billboard hot 100.
[Music]
it looks like cardi also treated her
entourage to all the fun
megan the stallion's boyfriend and
frequent cardi collaborator
parkerson fontaine shared this hilarious
golf cart ride
[Applause]
meet me partisan helped co-write up and
cardi's previous single [ __ ]
featuring meg which also made it to the
top of the billboard hot 100 back in
[Music]
august
[Music]
earlier this month cardi performed both
of her recent singles at the grammy
awards
which received lots of criticism due to
its sexual content
but after up made it to number one on
billboard cardi revealed in a lengthy
caption on instagram that she plans to
address the haters on her next album
i feel like i've been in a lot of drama
i feel like people have thrown so many
things so many different crazy obstacles
a new chapter in my life that this is
that oh i got a whole lot
to talk about there's a lot of things
that i don't be saying that it's like
you know what every single time that i
say it
people eat me up for a live from it they
say i complained so much i said you know
what i'm just gonna put it in my music
then